welcome everyone to this workshop
tutorial about how to reproduce and
scale deep learning machine learning on
a communities with poly axon to give you
a quick overview about what I'm gonna be
talking about today we giving an
introduction about myself and the
project how it started and then I'm
gonna talk about how what is it that
polygon enables in terms of what I'm
trying to solve with this platform I
call it the experimentation workflow and
then I'm going to talk about like the
users that we try to target with the
this platform direct users in direct
users and then we are gonna dive into
some kind of like a demo tutorial and
you can follow this sort sorry but I'm
most probably sure you cannot do it
because you you need to have first a
cluster you can do that on a mini cube
but mostly you need also like to
download like images for for a docker
but also like install packages and the
internet will not a lot to do this
during the the the demo you are welcome
to ask questions if you don't understand
something or you want to have like some
clarification about like how things are
working and at the end I'm gonna give
like an overview but the roadmap of the
project for the the near term and you
can also like ask question about like
the generic question about the platform
so my name is Murat the I'm the author
of poly axon you can find in github and
Twitter this is my handles and I have a
background in software engineering
Applied Mathematics
after the engineering school I start
working in finance and banking then I
decided to switch to tech companies
where I was so basically in finance I
was doing mostly like software engine
were also like a quantitative
quantitative modeling mostly working
with the Gaussian copula and Monte Carlo
simulations and when I switch to tech
companies I was doing software engineer
also the design design analytic sense
poly exhausted as basically some rappers
around
the first version of tensorflow when it
was basically just providing very low
api so it was very hard to to do
anything especially when they they were
upgrading every every time it was really
hard to get any model to work again so
at that time also like cameras was not
targeting tensorflow specifically it was
also mostly it was used with death piano
and yeah last year in September I just
decided like to add more stuff around by
accident by providing like some maths
pounders for for kunuk is trying to have
also like tracking for metrics or
producing like experiments and doing a
lot of things and yeah I'm still working
on it right now
so what does boil eggs don't do so the
the main objectives of this platform is
basically to enable the users to iterate
faster on their algorithms so basically
you simplifying how we can access to
powerful machines and do experimentation
with the different kind of like
frameworks and libraries one of also the
main ideas is like it can be deployed
anywhere you can use it in your in your
computer by so basically clever
leverages communities to have this kind
of like possibility of the the platform
so we can install it on mini cube or any
kind of cloud platform or if you have
also like an on premise cluster it also
tries to solve issues related to work
with disability and we will talk about
that when organs are talking about like
the experimentation workflow it's open
source so basically it's targeting
everyone who wants to rely on open
source solutions I think and the reason
he is especially for data science lot of
companies start using like often sources
the main way to build machine learning
models and also like deploy them all so
one of the ideas is that it should work
with any kind of like library and
since its lever is also like the
container technology whatever you want
to use it should be like useful whatever
you can also like run on a on a Linux
machine it should be also like running
with for the accident so basically you
just provide how it works is just
basically creates docker images and run
your code inside this docker images most
of the data scientists also don't know
how to use docker and they don't need to
know how to use blocker so the platform
simplifies is basically by just saying
for example what kind of like live
videos you want you want to use for this
experiment and everything is done behind
the scene with the platform to create a
docker image started somewhere if you
want you have access to GPU it gives you
like if you if you need like oopsy
pieces give you CPUs and yeah and the
platform should be used by single users
who want some kind of like organization
for their data science and machine
learning
obviously if you are just running one
experiment and you're you're not scaring
about what's the results you don't need
to use this platform but if you want to
have some kind of organization for
future and you want to know what
experiment has which results what
outputs artifacts you might think about
having something or organize it also
like targets large teams by that is
basically trying to help teams to have
some kind of like collaboration and
basically have some kind of like role
management where you can fortunately
view some experiments contributors and
experience or not access to any of these
so what is the experimentation workflow
on how I understand or at least like how
what I'm trying to choose to solve this
platform so when you start like doing
some kind of like machine learning that
you're targeting some kind of rack
production models you would start with
some kind of notebook I think you
already did that today with other
workshops I start doing some kind of
like exploration doing some kind of like
experiments in in the notebook and then
this the code starts growing and you
start like eating the same kind of like
problems that software engineers have so
you think about that some kind of
version control system like gets to
track all the changes of your code
the problem is that you don't know when
you start the next one we don't know if
you are using the right to get comment
or not so basically sometimes you just
change some kind of values and then you
run the experiment and then to two hours
they say we don't know if you if you
committed before or after and that
becomes really hard that's why I also
like we try to manage pretty much all
this kind of like phases of the the
project one of the things also you do is
like your code is not only responsible
for the core machine learning algorithm
so today you you saw a lot of things
around how to use tensors and how to
build like some kind of architecture but
most of the code will go like into data
cleaning decent management's enhancement
of the data like augmentation and many
other like aspects and this becomes
easily like a big project because a lot
of people with substance abusing and
then you don't know how the whole
workflow is is going so once you have
like an experiment running you will get
like some results and most probably you
will not be satisfied with the results
so what you do is like physically you
tweak the parameters you run again maybe
you need like hippies to go faster and
after a couple of experience you you
want to basically create a huge space of
parameters and just do some Travis or
this space with some kind of like
otherwise I go seems like biasing
optimizations or other like tools and
once you start doing that you will have
like a huge problem because you don't
know what experiment generated what kind
of like artifacts logs where how to
access them should you just say [ __ ] in
machines how to link between these kind
of things and even if you are satisfied
with one of them the results you might
want to like deployed is somewhere and
you need to tell the either you will
send this by email or like you just
package it you put it in zip somewhere
upload it but anyways it's like a huge
probably cause like the developer needs
to know what kind of I mean if also like
you are having this problem with
staleness of the models which means that
like every week for example you need to
train on new model new data because like
this is common like
online and you have also like this kind
of like pipelines for like the point is
new model every time and sometimes you
also just want to share like the results
with your the rest of your team compare
results and basically someone is leaving
the team and you want to reproduce
everything that's he did before leaving
and you don't know how I mean you will
real real I rely most probably on the
documentation that you wrote you need to
install this and this and probably will
hit like some kind of edge case because
you forgot to mention one of the
dependencies and then you cannot
musically you have a huge technical
depth you have no kind of like knowledge
distribution among your your team
members and this is what the the
platform is trying to solve and in terms
of like the users that the platform is
also targeting most most probably like
the data scientists and machine learning
engineers obviously like it you have
also if you are doing a lot of
discipline and you have like data
analysts but in order to use this kind
of like classroom you need a company his
classroom running and that's required
some kind of like DevOps most most
probably like as a software engineer as
a deeper scientist you may not know how
to set up a cluster and you don't need
to because what you want to do is
basically just iterate as fast as
possible on your algorithms so basically
that the platform is providing a lot of
ways to tweak to tweak it in terms of
like because it's already Inc has inside
it's like a data base it has a radius
for everything that is fast it has a
Robbie thank you for like talking with
all the services inside it has also like
a docker internal docker because all the
images you don't want to publish them in
the public in public registries but you
want them just inside for either for
compliance reasons or just for having
like fast access to like this kind of
like images so basically this is where
the devops
come to play they are not back using the
plasma but they are providing the
platform for other like users and once
you have like some kind of experiments
already
that you have good results with and you
want to deploy it in well most of all
you will talk with some software
engineers to take these models and put
them in production and it should be also
like as easy as possible to have this
kind of like access who can access in
terms of like engineers anyone who has
access to the cluster to the machine or
should it be like something some
abstraction where you are only providing
this kind of like values to some people
that you trust so to come to give a
concrete like words of how all these
things come together gana starts with
something simple I'm going to first of
all we are going to talk about like how
to install the platform what is it like
to install the fully axel so the first
thing is like we have in order to deploy
folio x1 you need to have a cluster
kubernetes cluster if you have a coop in
his class or most probably you have also
the hand package manager because it's
office official pack packaging manager
for communities and it's from there it's
very easy you just basically target him
to our our charts basically repository
and then you just install the the
platform installing the platform
requires a lot of tweak I mean there's
already sensible kind of like defaults
to install it on your mini cube or even
for a cluster but if you want for exact
replication you want to have more kind
of like control over how the database is
like working how the how the the
internal rabbiting queue is working you
most most probably want to have a look
at how all the parameters that the the
platform is providing if you need GPUs
how many like replicas you want for the
API how many replicas you want for the
worker are you doing a lot of hyper
parameter tuning and there's a lot of
question that you need to ask if you
want to do persistence if you want to
provide a high availability for all
these kind of like components once you
have like the class running you need
also like to install
the the the command-line interface which
is basically just people install poly a
kazan CLI i have it already installed so
nothing so once you install it you have
a couple of like comment that you can
interact with the the API is sure enough
more alright so yeah you have a couple
of like comments or interacted with the
platform and the the first thing okay I
need to do it off for the other one so
once you install the poly x1 on your
kubernetes cluster you will get like
some kind of like instruction how to
link the command line interface or the
API us API with the the the rest of the
platform so basically depending on your
configuration you might have an ingress
or load balancer or node port so there
was like different ways how you can
install it in this case I have I have it
with an ingress so it provides some kind
of like step that I need to follow I
need to get like the IP where these
where the platform is installed and the
port for HTTP and the port for
WebSockets and I need just to set up all
these kind of things so that's basically
there is a configuration created
somewhere you can also like have more
control where you want to serialize this
configuration and once you get that
basically can you can log you can log
into the platform regarding the user so
when when you deploy the platform in the
hand charts you can have access you can
have control over how the user the
routes user that the first user that the
platform has
like in terms of an email name and
password if you don't provide any
password the the platform will just
generate a random password and then you
can get access to this random password
afterwards if you are the the cluster
admin so once you have kubernetes
polygons installed on communities you
can log into the platform so logging is
basically there's a different way to log
in you can just say for example routes
so you're logged in you can basically
start doing some kind of so the first
thing is like creating projects in this
case I already have a project created in
fact I have already a project with a
couple of experience because I thought
that I would not have access to the
Internet and I was like already trying
to do some stuff but India any I needed
like Internet to do anything so I have
already like couple of projects
installed you can also like see them in
the dashboards
so I have a couple of project I already
like created run some experiments there
take some times because the internet is
not it's not that good so it's at the
wrong user and yeah I have couples so a
projects in poly axon is more or less
the same as in github you have some kind
of like problem that you want to solve
you create a project and then you start
have you have like some kind of code
that you want to execute and you have to
execute it in different ways that's what
we call experiments so the thing is like
everything is constructed around like
primitives in polygons there is like
multiple primitives like there is the
build a job we will see all these kind
of things experiment experiment groups
operations and pipelines that's
something that's is not already it's not
yet in the in the platform but this is
the kind of like primitive that the
platform provides once you have a
project created and initialize you can
basically start so I have some kind of
like code here I have distributed run
some some Python code for running like
for example can check this one I think
it's with my torch I have some code that
I want to execute it could be executed
with GPU or with CPU and it has like
some parameter that I can't pass okay I
can pass you and basically to start this
this code I just need to run yeah
actually should have done this so
basically I needed to upload some code
before start prying I already uploaded
the code because again the same problem
with the Internet so basically once you
upload the code put the eggs on create a
git commit inside so it has also like
another it tracks also all your all your
codes internally so that doesn't give
you any chance of like making errors I
mean you can rely of course on github or
whatever but if you are uploading the
code and you're not using an external
repo and providing the the hash that you
want you to run the the experiments with
it will just create a gate comment to
know exactly that
it used that
of the Dakota and you can always when
you restart an experiment it will result
with the exact exact same code once you
creates an experiment what polygon does
basically starts a built fort so
basically this is couple of visits okay
this is a large project let's go to
something simpler so say we'll just do
the same thing so we are going to run
some code here rock vortex again
so this is again the same thing we just
created an experiment and once you
create an experiment the project as I
said there is a bill that is getting
created if there is a so basically it's
running I can also like get to that
build and get the logs I can get the
pass if there's already like some logs
that I did not see and follow to get
anything getting streamed okay yeah so
basically the build that we had is
already created and most probably that
the experiment is going to be strong so
if we check the project again
experiments we see that our experiment
is running can also like get the
experiments you can do a lot of things
with getting the experiments ID you can
get the help for example and see all the
things that you can do with these
experiments you can track the statuses
like a twitch at what phase the
experiment is right now so basically 22
created building scheduled so building
is basically creating the the poker
world schedule is like put somewhere in
the kubernetes cluster and sorting is
basically just a phase in companies were
invited that everything is fine and then
we should start the experiments and
running is basically running your
experiment once the experiment is
running Polly axon we finished Polly I
can remove this experiment from the the
kubernetes cluster to free the the
resources so for example if you have
very limited GPU you don't need to so if
he wants to experience these finishes
like follow the nonsense some signals to
basically kill everything related to
that experiment to feed those GPUs and
keeps everything related to that
experiment somewhere for example we can
always get to the logs of that
experiment
so so if there's like some logs created
it will just show us all the loads of
for that experiments you can also like
get the same kind of things with the
dashboard so that was the polygon
tutorial so if there is like some logs
you will see the logs if there is like
some kind of metrics reported you will
see the metrics in this case we don't
have too many too much only it was a
very short experiments it will tell you
like the the build that it's used for
creating data experiments and many other
like kind of like metadata that you can
you can see once you have this very
first version you might probably be
satisfied with the results or not but
most probably not there's also like one
thing is like when you start this
experiment I it's create it does a lot
of things its downloads the data goes
through the data that does some kind of
like operations and run the experiments
but what you want to do in general is
like you want to split this to two
things running the experiments and doing
anything that is related to data
management's so that's why in poly actin
we have different another type of
primitives
it's called jobs so for example a job
could be just like download the data and
put it somewhere on your volumes that
you provided here for example I have
this download data file and I want to
run it with the polygon file so so I
started an experiment but I did not talk
how poly eggs and knows how to start the
experiments and like package the docker
and all these things so four legs and
comes with the specification file this
is how for example you tell what kind of
like primitive you want to run is it
like a job is it a build is it like an
experiments it's a pipeline you tell
it's also like how to create that that
job in terms of like what kind of like
build image you want to create if you
want to install some kind of like
libraries for
so for example Kara's it will be just
like adding a line here where you say
peep installed carrots if you need to
install some other things basically just
provide a very easy way to do run inside
the docker image and then what you want
to run so in in this case I just want to
run and download data so if I do Polly
axon run and I speak if I if I want to
specify which file I want to use a use
man's F and I do the job then basically
it will start this this job if we go to
these projects and see that it was a job
created its building County where so
basically it's creating a build also
okay so almost it's now running and once
it runs you can start like the
experiments afterwards knowing that
already they say is somewhere the way
you manage also like to do way to
organize also like this is kind of like
data and also like not accessing the
same data so as for example imagine you
have a job and you're accessing the data
and you basically changed that data the
next data science is like relying that
that the data is the same but you
already pre processes so relax don't
provide some kind of like pets so we
have data where you should only access
in read mode of course if you are the
cluster admin you can give yourself any
kind of like access but in general it
should be like you access to the data in
only read mode and your jobs will have a
path that's Ferguson creates that
follows some kind of like some kind of
like structure basically the projects
that it's been like it belongs to what
kind of like user and it will give it
some this path in like the outputs and
whenever you want to run an experiment
you just say I want to have the outputs
of that that object that job or that
experiment or for that matter because
you can have also like jobs that acts on
the outputs of an experiments for
example sending them doing some kind of
checks for example later on before like
deploying or doing whatever so we
started an experiment
that maybe maybe were like satisfied on
lots we might want to start the the same
experiment with different kind of like
declarations so here is a bit more
complex and so that I will show you
first the the first experiment that I
run the first experiments it was also
like very simple I just need Jack to
have access to tensorflow and I want to
run my model the second experiments
maybe I'm not super satisfied with the
results I want to have to change some
parameters I want for example to have
this batch size this number of steps I
want to do like six iterations I want to
change the learning rates and drop out
and many other things and you pass all
these values here so so this time I'm
not going to use run no I'm gonna also
specify that I want to use this specific
file so another experiment is created
you can see that it's starting somewhere
and this experiment will have all the
decryption that you created the thing is
like once you start doing this one two
three finds you you're not going to be
like every time going to your terminal
and and something another experience so
the next phase is basically Sutton a
group of experiments but before doing
that for example I want as I said like
here I did not provide a lot of a lot of
metrics some experiments have more
metrics that I thought I provided for
example but this is just to have an
overview but like that the exponent but
what you want to do most probably is
like if you go to all your experience I
want to see for example that the one
that I run before but I want to run I
want to see how how those might retire
ported with tensor board instead of
instead of poly exons and metric metric
step so but I don't also make it really
easy to start a tester board you don't
need to run it locally the way you saw
things about
basically you have different weights so
if you do tensor what sort what what is
it going to happen is that basically
pull axon creates some kind of like a
job run in kubernetes and it grazes
servers service around it it's like a
headless service you cannot access it
from outside of the platform and then
there is like some kind of like load
balancer that knows how to redirect the
users that are authorized to see that
project to access to that tech support
so since we did not specify what kind of
experiments I want to see in the tensor
vault it just created a tensor work for
the whole project there is different way
to start the tensor body concerns it for
a very specific experiment if in this
case it's very it's fine because we have
only a couple of experiments with their
evaluation but imagine if you have over
again a start like an experiment with
200 the experiment running concurrently
and in that case it doesn't probably
make sense to start all those all those
to put all those experiments in one
interval so I'm going to stop this one
and I'm gonna say for example I want to
I want to so once it started its you
cannot access it anymore I'm gonna say
for example I want to start the 10
supports for these experiments and not
for the whole project so we just provide
the same way I want like the experiments
ID and then you have again another job
run in somewhere you can have more
control over we will talk about that
house where the job should be running in
your kubernetes cluster most probably
you don't want everyone to have access
for example like for the tensor board
probably don't need people to access GPU
unless they need that GPU so when you
don't say anything
communities just like run the the jobs
somewhere where is possible in my case I
have a lot of notes so basically I don't
care but for if you have like some
resources that you don't want to like
waste them on some jobs that don't
require those resources for example GPUs
you need to have like this kind of like
annotations that we will see in
in the specification file so now we
started tech support for one experiments
so the tensor board will have access
only to the experiments we don't show
all the expose the only one that was a
short sex room that we did so it doesn't
have like a lot of metrics it have one
evaluation but yeah so now we can stop
it again don't need to use it anymore
now I'm gonna start an experiment group
so basically I saw that I first like one
in the experiment the job directly and
then I changed some kind of parameter it
started another experiment and probably
I'm not also satisfied I might do that
manually a couple of times and maybe I'm
not super like enthusiastic about like
just trying couple of values manually so
what I'm gonna do is just and I'm gonna
run with some kind of like hyper
chemistry search and in this case I'm
gonna start a grid search can look at
the so
so we have one group that is running can
get that group also like the experiments
inside that group
to actually ate that was the concurrency
so we have a group of experiments that
have ten experiments and I want to run
five of those experiments in parallel so
basically well it's just the concurrency
that we have here so we have a new
section different than the one that you
saw we changed the kind of this this
primitive it's a group and we say that I
want to run okay so this is a random
search that's a grid search I want to
run ten experiments in total and I want
to run five experiments in parallel and
that's the concurrency and I provide
like the search space that I want to
search so basically I want to go through
the learning rates with the linear space
from 0.001 with five steps I have to
draw pasta that I want to pick with the
same probability and to activation also
that want to pick with the same
occupation with the same probability you
have different kind of like we can check
the the sections so we have different
kind of like different kind of like
distribution that you can use for the
hyper pharmacist search so if you are
using a grid search you cannot use a
continuous distribution because you
cannot just you cannot have so how great
search work is just using a Cartesian
product between all the values that you
have and you cannot say for example I
want to pick a uniform distribution
because it's just one value but you have
to provide like it's it's gonna be like
random so you can use for example the
values the range linear space
logarithmic spec or geometric space and
for anything else there was a couple of
there's a couple of algorithms that
polygon provides there is a random
search based on optimization and - and
all these way and all these algorithms
can accept these kind of things for
example if I have the very
we said that we use for activation to
value stick on similar than and what is
the other one in the real ooh it was
like probably 50/50 if I want to give
for example ooh like more probably I can
use for example the p-value so for
example I would say well you should be
picked with 80% chance and the other one
20% chance you can use also like a
uniform distribution and it is like
other kind of things and in our case we
used we used random search
this is like the specifications this is
it's basically that one of the simplest
one and by default it pull eggs and use
research and in this case we use the
random search and if you want to have
access to much performance like a
grounding algorithms you can use for
example hyper pens basically I can show
like some experiment that I use hi
program good so how it works is
basically you have a resource that you
want to optimize you say for example how
many iterations you want to use there's
not a fire missiles that you can't play
with and you say for example the net
process is the resource that I can't
play whenever you do a new suggestions
basically it gets a new a new resource
that you are going to like use for
creating these suggestions and in this
case is like the number of steps so how
it works is like the first time when you
start your experiments you can solve for
exactly 200 experiments running
concurrently and once you get like the
metrics back you will sound like of
doing some optimizations and then you
say for example I want to start how for
like third or whatever there was like a
formula behind and basically only some
only some experiments will be picked
only the most performance ones and we
can also have control over if you want
to do some kind of like if you want to
for example in this case I'm using like
the number of steps for the first time
it's gonna be like two steps and the
next time it's gonna be for example 20
steps so if for example one experiment
is basically performing really badly you
don't want to start it so you don't want
to allocate more resources to the to
that experiment you just start with that
other extremist it has most ponies and
resources
and you have to provide like what you
want to optimize for so in this case I'm
using loss you can use fubar if you have
a matrix called fubar and I say I want
to minimize this this this this metric
if you are using for example accuracy
you would say I want to maximize this is
this metric so how it worked is
basically create all these allegory this
is first generation of experiments it
gets all the metrics back and it is like
all the most promising experiments and
then just allocate more resources to
these to those experiments and you can
also like say if you want to resume the
experience or just restart them from
scratch and there is vison optimizations
there's like a couple of things that you
can use there's like different
acquisition functions and different kind
of like priors
they will be also more adding for
example random search random forests and
so on and so forth and the same way you
need to provide a metric that you want
to optimize you can also provide an
early stopping for these groups so that
you say for example once one of these
metrics which like this value for
example I want to minimize the loss so
any any if any of the the experiment
that I run which for example a value of
0.01 or less I want to solve the whole
thing I don't want to keep like wasting
the resources of the of my cluster
because I already like it the value that
I wanted to to reach and yeah so this is
how how we construct these these
algorithms we can also like to another
so we can check again the experiments if
they're still running ok so it's already
finished we didn't provide any kind of
like any any kind of like early stopping
or anything he just went through all the
the random search we can check also the
values here on the dashboard so if you
go to the experiment groups you will
find that there is one experiments and
we can see that all those experiments
can check also like the values of those
experimental metrics now you can do this
also directly from here so we see the
experiment definition by we can get also
like the metrics of those experiments
for the declaration if you want to
compare and
the values this one so for example which
experiment started with what kind of
like values if you for example see
that's one of the experiment is
something that you like and you want to
resort it it's just doing this
experiment and then you provide the idea
of that experiment that you want to
restore for example this one and then
you start it this will just basically
create an experiment based on the other
experience it's basically uses the same
kind of like values and by the same
values I mean like the same kind of
configuration here if there is like some
kind of note that you want to use that
experiment on it will be like started on
the same experience it will use the same
docker image and many other like things
that's the platform tracks so now we saw
and so yeah and they said the last thing
that I want to say what also like tensor
boards is that you can also start a ten
support for group for exactly four to
compare the values so we saw that we can
suffer and turns about for projects for
an experiment you can also do as do the
same thing for for the group basically
in this case it will only like among all
the the experiments in the project it
will only show the experiments inside
this very specific group
yes oh yeah
what do you mean by the okay it could be
any kind of like key value metric so
basically you just provide the name of
the metric so as I said like you can
provide food oh yeah so I can show for
example sorry yes okay so how do we
report metrics to the platform so it's
called model so in this case I'm writing
a running a file call called mall and at
the very end of the experiments I'm just
doing send metrics
the send metrics is coming from a helper
that's that the platform provides so
this is why in in my in my polygon files
I always do this tip install here
because I want to use the so basic and
just saying that I want in my bill to
install so like the helper that the the
platform provides so that I can use a
couple of things so it's not only using
the this to send metrics it's also like
it does a lot of things and for example
can go to another project that has code
that can run that can run this abuse the
this reviews it yeah so in this case for
example I'm using a distributed
experiment with one worker and one one
parameter server and in order to run
this because in the end what does
polygon we just create the topology of
all these kind of like pots and creates
for example in the case of tensorflow
it creates headless service so that they
can they can communicate through the G
RPC server that they creates and in
order to know where each one of these
spots is running you need to know the TF
config and all these kind of like things
and that's why you use I mean you can
use
any kind of like other code for because
in the end you just like export some
kind of environment variable but to keep
things really easy you can install this
helper and then you get for example
where should I put my outputs and
basically it's just here otherwise you
can just like go directly and then get
it from the environment variable in the
case of for example that if I want to
get the cluster definition how for
example in this case I have like two
workers one master and IPS so let's
start for example this distributed
experiment so if I do this
what your fault
like up it's okay so building did not
hit yet communities to start the jobs
but once it's starts creating the jobs
for that experiment we see that it's
it's something that yeah so it's now
running if we do the jobs see that it's
created like a master worker can get
also like the logs automatically so if
you are doing for example if this
reviews of the learning at this point
you would probably like the getting the
logs from each server with some kind of
like SSH or or some kind of other method
in the case of pol X and it just gets
all your or your logs in one output so
once we hit like one of the PS or the
worker it will also show with the
different color so in this case like
here's the worker and this is like
camera like out of the box it could be
like very easy to do like a distributed
learning all three workers but imagine
for example I just keep this like
working in the background I change the
following on this this distributed file
and say I want to use now two workers if
you do that manually I don't know if you
can even do this menu like you will go
to each machine and then start exporting
some run some values on like what sports
is like the other machine is running and
stuff so in this case it's gonna be like
basically the same I'm just saying I
want to run with this distributed this
is the distributed the experiments and
same way if I do the jobs for this one
it's all for zero
hopefully it's already running so it
creates a five-to-one master to worker
into PS and I can also like it'll log
for this one it's also like brings all
the locks of obviously if you are
running distributed experiments with I
don't know 20 or like 40 workers you
will not get anything these
pleasant from seeing all these locks
coming from all these these values so
what you can do is for example you can
say well I don't want to get all these
logs I want to get only the logs for
example from this job and this will only
stream the logs for that job and you
don't need I mean if even if you are
using communities at this moment and you
are doing this kind of like this tubular
know what you will do is like you CTL
logs get that boat on you need to know
the pole and it probably has a hash and
all these kind of things in this case
you can always get the experiments and
all the values lists that experiments
easily you can also get all these kind
of like things so it's a different
project you can get the same kind of
like information also from the from the
dashboards it's a cipher in this case
and this is our last experiments and you
can see that it's running like four you
can have like more at the thing is like
there's many more other information that
the platform tracks did not make it make
it yet to the dashboard and the CLI but
it's gonna come in the future so yeah so
that's that's basically how the
experiments in experimentation works and
once you start like doing a lot of so if
I go back again to the other like
running the groups and I decide for
example to run hi prevent with like 200
explain so let's check the hyper events
example nope that's not projects
so say I want to run for example hyper
event and want to run 200 experiments in
concurrently and I have a couple of
things that I want to try and if you do
that a couple of times it will be really
hard to navigate all the I mean imagine
if you are also like doing this many
other like all this kind of extreme some
yeah so so how how do we get like from
this file with all these like just
distributions and values into like
experiments where you say for example
this experiment runs with this with this
specific value so how it work is like
this on the command line interface
there's like specification validator
that just check that the specification
specification is correct it send this to
the to the to the server and if you go
to the tutorial projects it will start
if you go to the experiment groups we
have a new experiment group it's called
its hyper event it has created two
hundred forty three experiments and it's
run in two hundred we can check them
here and how it works is basically it's
also like parses that that's
specification and obviously if you have
here if you have for example a uniform
value a uniform distribution for
learning rate is basically just gonna
sample that value for each experiment is
gonna just pick for example here it's
gonna pick a value with 50 percent
chance either 0 25 or 0 3 and for real
0.1 and for sigmoid 0.8 so whatever you
specify in the specification it just
gonna
there was a parser behind and then it
just got up basically used basically
behind the scene just numpy for like
something all these values creating an
experiment and explore basically telling
like how to run the experiment with the
specific values obviously all these
these
parameters here they need to to match
somehow your code if you are just
generating a parameter say fubar for
example with I don't know log uniform
distribution or whatever I mean it just
you are just gonna create an experiment
with that full bar but that fubar is not
used anywhere so right now we have a lot
of experiments running and ok so maybe I
don't have to see everything I just want
to see for example the and that's that
the next thing I want to show is like
the search or like the filters he did so
once you hit like a number of
experiments in your classroom yesterday
I was bit when I started when I
provision this cluster I thought that
yeah I met I didn't know about the
internet and everything and I started
like a huge cluster I was running three
thousand experiments in terror
just to test how how the how the the
platform can handle a lot of traffic and
everything and basically I managed to
run 13,000 experiments in less than two
hours and basically searching what
experiment failed and what experiments
succeeded is it's gonna be like hard if
you are doing this manually so the
platform provides a way for example I
can go to sort of the kick starts so if
I want to check only the experiment that
failed during the whole thing I can use
the statuses status think and then only
to experiment rendering like so as we
said like it was 13000 expert on a few
see it so it's like 13,000 experiment
that was running yesterday and only to
like felt I can also like saying I want
to get the fail okay and this case is
not gonna work but like for the other
experiments it was it was not this one
this
I might be interested in experiment
that's are either have created or
running or not enough trying like starts
it for example okay no okay I can do
also like the negative or this just
return anything that that doesn't belong
to this to that to status of obviously
can also the thing is you can also check
if we if we do for example I want to
check anything that we long to this
build number 39 and number 50 for
example or remember I don't know how
many does this experiment has for
example I want to get all all the
experiment that have built forty five so
you know exactly like all the experiment
that run with the specific for example
blocker container or get comments yes
yeah that's exactly what I did
okay so restarting experiments I can
actually show ya I'm gonna go to the
documentation because it's actually
better to show that there
so there's different ways to result and
experiments there is like just if you
need first if you want so if you want to
just restart the experiment and you
don't care about the previous results
you just do restart
you can also resume so basically you
stop an extra moment and you decide in
the future that okay I'm gonna stop it
right now but I want to provide like
more CPUs for these experiments you stop
it and then you just say I want to
resume if you want to restart and have a
different configuration for example you
want to override the learning rate we
just provide an overriding file you did
so basically how does overwriting works
I'm gonna tree if I have you okay so
this one is so here I'm actually can use
any other file but I'm saying that I
want to use the file for example like
one file that has a group or an
experiment I want to override the builds
it's like docker compose basically you
can just say for example Polly axon run
or like we start and then you provide
the first file and then the second file
and then it will just you know
so basically latest so it will just like
merge them by taking the last one and
then overriding the first one and that
the same also like for restarting you
can just say I want to restart but this
with this with this file and you say for
example I'm gonna overwrite for example
two values like the learning rate and
the activation for example for some
specific layer somewhere and it should
also like work now that you know all the
experiments are so do you want yourself
an experiment to resume an extreme do
you use the previous experiment no you
don't use any experiments because all
the experiments are immutable whenever
you run an experiment it has an ID test
some kind of pets in one of the volumes
for the logs one path for the outputs
and has like what kind of build it's
used and pretty much a git commit and
any other things when you restart you
can say for example I wanna restart
about the with the latest code in that
case it will basically use the same
configuration and it's quick it will
create a new
a mutable experiment again with the same
kind of configuration it will only
override for example the code or like
for that case like the learning rate for
example but it's completely - two
different experiments and you can
compare them and you can also check all
the logs and everything everything is
immutable basically I mean you have the
least access you can delete like
experiments from the platform but it's
not advisable because you can also for
example if you are using a job and you
want to you can so the thing is like you
can give to experiments or like
experiment groups for example this
number 39 you can give it like a name I
mean you can give it a name description
and too much a lot of things for example
you just say description and say for
example that was a bad group and like
tag it with some pie data for example
and give it like a name that's unique
name is like only for that thing and
basically all this kind of information
helps you for example for the search
when you go back you can use all these
kind of tags and stuff too so if you
have thirteen thousand experiences
really have to paginate through them so
you need to have like as much
organization as possible so that you can
always get back to the same kind of like
group and all these kind of things and
yeah the name is a I don't know Group
one why whatever oh yeah one more please
okay
okay oh it's not - be also it's - G so
I'm screwed
yeah you can okay and it's tags not
tagged yeah you get its offices so
there's a lot of things that you need to
look like it's pretty much trying to get
to like what you use what are you using
in other like platforms like github or
whatever so it's kinda like closed right
now the only way to interact with the
API is through the CLI or through the
REST API but hopefully in the future
we'll have some time to also like
upgrade the - also you can also do all
these kind of things from here so if we
go here we will find that okay so we
have now a description and we have a tag
here and you can use that for example
although we don't have a lot of text we
can they say for example cherries and
then Phi Beta and if we get us but
imagine if you have like more than it
will have like much more impact so going
back to the specification you have as I
said like there was a couple of like
primitives that you can use job
everywhere every one of these
specification have couple of like
section that you can use as we said for
example for the experiments it has like
declaration environments I will talk
briefly about the environment you can
have like much more control with these
environments in terms of like the port
that you run in if you want GPU if you
want to run it somewhere in the class or
very specific and also like if you want
to have some kind of like output coming
from other like jobs and stuff in the
group section you have the hyper
parameter tuning section that we that we
saw which has so much the seed the
matrix the the space that we want to
traverse and also like what kind of like
algorithm that we want to use so going
to for example the environments you can
have like a lot of control over what how
much CPU memory and GPU that you want to
use fun experiments if you provide any
of these values and you saw the
experiments it will result with the very
same kind of like so that's
two technical left or exactly if you're
running experiments and you reach some
results and the next time you read
something the experiment and probably
it's using GPU and you're not reaching
the same thing I'm not if you are really
caring about like this kind of like
compliance you can't have this kind of
like resource section and then you
provide exactly how much resource you
want to run this experiment with this is
also like could be useful for example if
you have a team and for example two guys
I'd like for exact the interns and you
don't want to provide the interns with
the GPUs you just say for example it can
actually GT it can have also so the
thing is once you start like hitting
some kind of like scalability levels you
don't you cannot use only one volume for
the data and most probably you have data
scattered in different kind of volumes
you can have also like access to
different volumes for each experiment
you can just say for example I want to
use volume 1 2 3 and the dev ops
basically just provided with the names
what he knows how to mount is one of one
of these volumes is NFS the otherwise
cluster FS and basically he knows some
some of them are coming from the the
host node for example and basically the
the platform will know how to mount all
these kind of like volumes in your pod
and have and give and give you access
directly to all this with the path and
everything not selector so imagine you
have for example a lot just say for in
this case I have 15 notes because I was
thinking I'm gonna be running three
thousand experiments in parallel and for
for instance I want one team to be only
like targeting like 3.3 nodes I can
always say for example you can have
access to the GPU as we said with the
resources but imagine if you have like a
Tesla Etienne one and the other one is
like 100 whatever reference and you want
to use that specific GPU that latest
money you don't want to say for example
two communities I want to use any GPR
not to use that GPU can reference which
no do you want to use and basically
polygon redirects and schedule let's
experiment on the on that very specific
node you can have so as I said like at
the beginning the the platform can run
anything that can be run in poker so
basically any kind of code but we have
very
we have some kind of like specifications
for some some some platforms namely for
tensor flow for height or MX nets and
[ __ ] volt and the reason why is that
these platforms provide this
distribution learning and as we just
said like for exactly if you want to run
an experiment with like five workers
five PS or whatever it's gonna be really
hard to do that manually and the reason
also is that for example you want the
workers to work with the GPU and the PS
to have only CPU for example because
they don't do much work and you can have
this kind of like things also with the
resources for each one of these workers
running your explain distributed
experiments the same thing with the the
pi torsion MX that you have a lot of
control over the resources the the notes
where you want to use them and yeah when
I was yeah last thing is like most of
you will be probably using a notebook
before even hitting like this kind of
like code that runs so I have already
like running and not a book is also like
as easy just like folio acts on notebook
and you can also have as much control in
terms of like where you want to run the
notebook how much resources and many
other things so I have already like for
example project that I have a notebook
with this one reviews and once you start
like a notebook is also creating a pod
for that not work it creates a headless
server and gives you access to the not
work then knows what cannot cannot be
accessed for example from and almost not
logged in user and also or even a logged
in user but doesn't have like the right
to access that so that's not book and
yeah you can run the same thing as you
did for example like the tutorials that
you saw this morning for example you can
run them also as if you have for example
couple of like users in your
organization and you have like GPUs and
they have like very old for example
computers can they can run pretty much
anything and then you want to give them
like access to the GPU you don't require
them to be like they've lost all so to
start all these experience and you can
basically also like yeah run things the
same
this is running somewhere in some cloud
platform and you don't you just give
give them like this kind of like
abstraction they don't need to access to
the class or Denali to SSH to any
machine it did you just provide the mode
like basically four legs will not work
start and then it says the same thing
once you are done with the Natsuki the
same way just say stop if you want to
make a comment after doing something
within most week you just do - - so
that's the help for for that yeah most
books are by default like running on
project level because it doesn't make
sense to run them like in external
groups because you have code in one
projects it's like the same way you do
the github you have your your code and
then you just access it in some kind of
like nose book you can start stop get
the URL if you for God's and okay that's
missing but it should be there should be
also like - - for commits after
finishing the work if you want to commit
that that work afterwards what else we
can talk about is so we saw that we can
use we saw the field training how we can
run project jobs jobs could be like as
we said like pre pre experiments or post
experiments or just like do something
kind of like operation you have a you
have different kind of like users in the
platform so you can have different also
roles
anyone can for example you can also
provide ways to log into the platform
through github github and bitbucket
and the users need to be activated by
one of the admins so basically if I
create a new user I just need to for
example activate that user or deleted I
can also give the users super super user
role basically to be also like admin of
the platform we saw the the clients you
can use also like the platform
wrathful way yeah so that's too much
we're going through like the most of the
the features probably I forgot something
but there's a lot of things that could
be done do you have any kind of
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
could you briefly outline the advantages
of using Pali accent yeah so as I said
if you are just doing a tutorial in
Pilate and you are gonna delete that
code afterwards you don't need that if
you are using for example if you want to
have like a production model that you
want to deploy somewhere and you know
that you're not going to hit that metric
that you are trying to get to after one
or three experiments like as we said we
just sounded like a huge experiment
group then you need somehow some
organization because as I said you can
forget like forgot like what kind of
like code you use what kind of
parameters you use what kind of like I
mean imagine if you are only having this
problem with scenes of the model every
week basically the model decreases in
terms of like metrics or like some kind
of performance and you want to retrigger
the the the retraining if you don't know
exactly if you are not really organizing
in terms of your work you might forget
something and this something could be
like really faithful in terms of like
reproducing that experimental just like
one in that experiment and if you leave
yeah you are your your colleagues out at
the mercy of your your documentation
basically if they can do anything with
with your codes so that's where you can
use the platform of basically having
some kind of organization for your
workflow okay hey you said experience
are kind of like commits is there kind
of a it you can make like within gateway
you can check the depth of your source
code right now what you can Romans yeah
right now what you can do is basically
as I said like you can show that the
parameter is used but there is no there
is no like showing like the code you can
see the comets you can also like
download the internal internal codes so
idea I do health here here we have
download the same was upload and you can
see all the the comets obviously for
each one of the experiments this is
something that needs to it's a lot of
work so for example this one used this
build and the build like has a hash
obviously you will you do it somehow
manually for now but there is no kind of
like page where you are showing for
example what kind of like code changes
change what about data so for data as I
said if you are running a job each job
will have like an output so we can this
so basically you would have like an
output where you are do once you get as
I said like there's like two kind of of
volumes let me show the the health
charts so persistence we have a couple
of things that we need to persist like
there's the logs there's a repose
there's the the uploads the data and the
outputs so data is something that of
course you can mount it as read/write
and all the users will have readwrite
and then they can delete anything or you
can say for example the data is only
accessible in read mode and every job
every experiment has an output switch is
in a different kind of volumes and if
you for example run in a job that does
some kind of processing of the data
segmentation whatever or like even
though it's something you just gotta put
it in the outputs and you refer
reference that job or that experiment
for the next externally you are doing
for example you are using the data to
keep for example doing like some kind of
resuming the
the training you just access to the
output and that's the day you don't
change the defense so you can have this
control if you provide read mode only
for the data and every job basically
does something it just export it to the
output and you have access to the
outputs for whatever other jobs needs
that output so that the data says
basically also immutable and obviously
since you are not deleting anything from
the platform all the jobs will have
their output somewhere and they organize
you can always also so basically if you
have a job you can do job output
- GE and then the ID for example and it
will download the office if you want of
course if it's not big otherwise you
will be waiting otherwise you can also
amount you can also like install Mineo
to have an s3 access to all your volume
but this sounds something that you need
also to talk with your DevOps for
experiments is the same thing if you do
experiments
- XP ID outputs it will get the utmost
for example if it's a tensor flow and
has some kind of like artifacts or
whatever some kind of like model that
you want to download is the same way but
it's always are organized in all the
volumes that you provide for the
platform and they would be I mean no
other job has the right to touch those
experience if you follow basically
there's some organization that you need
also to follow as I said if you provide
read Y to your users and they want to do
whatever having in the end they will do
whatever they want yeah yeah how do you
handle scaling so I mean if you run
three thirteen thousand experiments you
don't want to have idle a couple of
hundred instances around and cost you a
lot of money or if you otherwise only
run an experiment every two to three
days you don't want your GPU instance to
always run you want it actually to be
turned off and only turned on yeah I
mean as I said there was two ways to
turn off the experiments you can wait
for them to finish and if you're running
that manually kubernetes will not do
that for you or any other platform it's
will not just like kill because they
don't know what is what about what does
it mean to finish and kill for example
in experiments we have for example the
service learning
now there is like one policy for
termination if the master finishes
basically but icon send the signal to
all the workers to choose to stop doing
the job if you are running an experiment
group for example as you said and you
have early stopping once as I said like
once you hit that metric that you want
well the the platform will send a signal
to all experiments running to stop and
basically release the resources that
they are using at the moment if you did
not reach the the metric that you want
well basically the algorithm will keep
searching that's why basically you
started the group so that you search
through a large space search so that's
the only two things that you can do if
you are running an experiment that you
want to run it for three days then you
are responsible for probably for your
call I mean if yeah I mean like for
example if if you see many of the the
latest deep learning like models they
they require two week for example of
training you cannot just like say after
three days you need to stop experiment
some experiments you need to run for for
three days or for two weeks i from my
understanding if you run Jupiter
notebook you don't have experiments
right you just have a project yes no you
can't run experiments so you can have
for example I mean let's do it for one
of the project we can you can start and
not book for example I can start a lot
work for for these projects but I can
also start and it's not ok I don't know
field yeah I need a file probably won't
have fair for these projects so you need
the file so here for example I can start
here I have I have poly eggs almost book
file so I can just - poly eggs on run -
F sewing mas book starts - F for the
Aggies on what book this will start a
mas book in your projects and you can
still do run - f folio
for example when it starts by an
optimization for example and it should
work what you cannot do is upload code
and make git commits because you are
already acting on the on the the code at
that moment so for example if I if I try
to upload it will not allow me to do
that because the project's because when
you have like a notebook you are
probably doing also like some tweaking
in the code and you cannot just make a
comment over something that is already
changing okay but if you if you do that
that thing that you just said that
uploading a notebook and then doing some
changes on your notebook you can commit
the changes in the notochord opening I
mean in the platform no I mean as I said
like if when I starts running this
experiment group it will just run it
with whatever comment I provided or the
latest comment that's the platform has
but you cannot change the code anymore
until you stop the loss book because it
just like an overhead of like doing all
this kind of like who should the commits
first and all this kind of like yeah you
can also have you can upload the code
with the you can do also a lot of hook
starts - you and it will upload before
stuff in the notebook yeah yeah you do
some changes is locally yes why would
you do that [ __ ] if you have a
notebook also it's all the same totally
sorry in the notebook okay then can you
commit the changes yeah so when you when
you want to when you finish doing
whatever you are doing with the notebook
you can say stop or you can say stop - -
comments which means that I want to stop
the notebook and I want to keep the
latest changes that I've made when I was
working with the notebook and it will
make a comment with your latest changes
and then you can revert
commit back you have to synchronize then
so yeah and you need to occur to
communicate with because the code is on
the gates on the server not locally yeah
if there is no more questions would
probably like to talk a bit about the
near-term roadmap of the before like
finishing so yeah so basically right now
what I was like trying is like to have
some kind of workflow where you can run
experiments have as much automation as
possible in terms of like what to run
when how have reducibility
and the future is like as I said like
for example stainless of the model or
for example if you have some kind of
like triggers you have for exactly new
bucket in s3 and you want to run your
experience with the latest code from
that s3 right now what you can do is
basically use some air flow Muji and
there was like a workshop with Richie
where you are basically talking with the
API but I think it's also not ideal
because you will lose this kind of like
compliance where you are come if
something is coming from outside we we
don't have like much control over the
outside so basically Poli axon will be
providing a very simple abstraction for
pipelines and operation triggers that
for exactly you say I want to run or
retrain these various experiments but
whenever for example my model is start
the performance of my model start
decreasing or for example if it was like
new code need a new data for for exactly
in the database or like in some kind of
like bucket somewhere in s3 or or other
other platforms there's also like things
that I'm thinking about like web books
for example if you you can use gates as
the main source for gate for example you
push the code of the code to get and
there is a web hook that's triggers for
example the experiment to sauce and
that's the more or less the short term
and have like there are use cases for
the dashboard and now
and let's thank the speaker
[Music]